Megan hi I'm so excited to have you here
we have a bit of a history together
because I worked at Country Music
Television for a very long time and you
were in a country duo for quite some
time
I was actually we went down to Jamaica
together I know which was a lot of fun a
lot of fun well I mentioned that you
were in a country duo so I'm gonna take
it back a little to there because this
was a while ago now but Steel Magnolias
there was definite success with that you
know top five country hits you know
you're doing tours with Reba McEntire
Blake Shelton yeah all these people um
what was that experience like for you
kind of looking back on things now I was
super young yeah so it was I mean was
exciting was awesome you know to have
help from the radio and to do all the
things that we did it was like I was
hitting all my milestones and all these
things were written down I wanted to do
and I did them
[Music]
obviously was a struggle to I was in a
relationship and my ex was had issues
and so it was a lot I liked trying to
hold the ship together I guess and it
kind of it was exhausting honest with
you but it was a great great experience
and you learn a lot you know after Steel
Magnolias kind of disbanded in that
relationship broke up you spent some
time working on your own things and then
you did the voice season 8 which was
incredible tell me about that experience
of being on the voice and what that
meant for you to get out there again and
show yourself as a solo artist it was
cool I you know I wasn't planning on
auditioning for that at all
I was just literally I was in line at a
Panera Bread I was like a little cafe
thing I was getting ready to pay and I
got a phone call and the lady was like
hey I'm a producer for the voice she was
like if we watched over YouTube we
really love to have you come audition
and I was like okay let me think about
this like let me let me took out so I
called her back after I checked out I'm
I told her was eleven eleven which is
tattooed on my neck which is like my
sign right that things are good yeah so
I I was like dang so I called her and I
was like okay when do you want me there
and that was on a Friday and they flew
me out on a Tuesday well and I just got
there and it just kept kept advancing on
the show I wasn't expecting
megan is 29 years old but it's like she
came from a different time I've gained
some fans and I got to put out music and
I'm independent and so it's a great
thing for exposure that was gonna be one
of my questions for you because you did
come from big it was big machine
something the same big machine which if
people see it's a big machine there's a
lot of products where Taylor Swift was
on yeah for many years there's a lot of
pressures that come along with a label
like that you want to come out as
independent yeah what does that do for
you personally does that just give you
more freedom to express yourself in the
ways you want because the Megan I knew
back in the Steel Magnolias days
probably wouldn't maybe have been
allowed to have pink hair ya know it was
very constricted I mean I was very like
if they told you how to brush her teeth
you know yeah so you were very media
trained and it was very like this is
what you're gonna do and you know these
are the songs you're gonna sing it I
mean honestly I think with Steel
Magnolias we really fought for things
and so we got to you know sing a lot of
stuff that we wrote on the record which
is great which is great so there were
some things but honestly just like as
far as like self-expression it was it
was tough for me because I'm pretty
outspoken you are very outspoken and
that's something I really do appreciate
about you and that's why I wanted to
have you on the show because in
Nashville there are so many members of
the LGBTQ community yeah you know
working behind the scenes well like a
lot like everybody but the funny thing
is a lot of times I feel like even some
artists you know a lot of people are
afraid to either express their support
for the LGBTQ community because it is
you know the southern United States and
that's a much different demographic but
new have always shown your support yeah
so why do you feel like you connect to
the LGBTQ community I think that I'm a
weirdo no it's true
no it's true I feel like you know I I
don't know I've always loved people and
I grew up you know I was taught to just
love everybody I think you know in
Nashville ty Herndon started doing this
thing called this concert for love and
acceptance during CMA fest and he called
me the first one that they did and I
Scot not for big machine I was like
thinking to myself I'm like man if Ida
got this call when I was on big machine
I probably wouldn't have been allowed to
do this and so I was like hey I'll do it
so I did the first concert for love and
acceptance and I partnered with HRC and
I started doing some of the things that
I really wanted to do as an artist
before that I really wasn't kind of
allowed to logo on a major label which
is crazy but it just is true you know so
so yeah I think that's the best thing
about being independent is just being
able to express yourself and support the
things that you you know believe in and
so that's been the best part I always
joke that I have a drag queens Club it
there's so many cats into my closet it's
ridiculous I'm always just buying you
know anything sequins or glitter I'm in
but but yeah huge I mean all of
everybody that works with me as part of
the LGBTQ community and I just love that
energy around you do express yourself
you are outspoken and I don't know maybe
it was a two years ago you actually
performed a national anthem at an NFL
game and it caused headlines across the
world because you took a name yeah tell
me tell me about that because I know you
received death threats for that and
there was a lot of hate online about
that yeah it's crazy I think you know a
lot of that just what that movement got
really misconstrued you know it was like
oh you don't support the troops or you
don't support America and that's just
not true no it was meant to be a
peaceful protest you know to raise
awareness for the police brutality
against black people you know the US and
I've done a time for wounded warriors
and I've played for you know kids have
fallen soldiers and I've done all these
things with the troops and so I didn't
want it to the message to be lost you
know but at the same time it was I
booked that anthem before the Trump
presidency and I did not know what was
going to unfold you know and so it you
kind of I think in that moment it's like
you're making a statement whether you
kneel is all yeah so for me that was
so you had a spider while you were
sleeping now people don't know a brown
recluse is a spider that kind of hides
in that it's in southern US yeah yeah
and it actually is like a flesh-eating
spider yeah that's awful it's kind of
the worst thing ever I woke up I you
know you wake up you're like you don't
know what's happening and I thought my
face was stinging and then I literally
looked in my right hand and I was
holding the spider and I had just killed
it apparently in my sleep but yeah
they're all over in Nashville and so I
you know when you visit conceptually
don't lay your clothes on the floor I
have all these new rules for myself
follow those rules me I'm a freak about
it now you're still making music tell me
about bold like a lion came out yeah
that was about a year and a half ago is
my last record but I worked on that
thing for like two years
[Music]
now
I love to write I love to be creative
you know my my boyfriend and I have a
studio at Nashville's we're always
creating music and we're actually
working on a new project now that's
exciting that's more in the country vein
growth so I'm really really excited to
kind of get back to that and kind of be
you know more the acoustic instruments
and more of the soulful vocals does
country just keep drawing you back I
just like real instruments and I like
real songs that tell story I think that
that's the part about country that
really keeps pulling me back into it you
know so I think I don't know that's the
kind of record I want I want to make and
you know the last record was a little
more pop I don't like to box myself in I
kind of like to make the music that I
want to make and what I'm feeling
inspired by at the time from everything
you've experienced and lived through
what message would you give to people
who are within the LGBTQ community who
are just trying to push on and you maybe
embrace their own weirdness like we said
ya know what message would you get to
those people I think just you know just
be yourself I know that sounds so cliche
but it's true
like I've I've tried to just stand
strong and Who I am always and not waver
and I think that that has served me I
think people know if people know when
you're when you're authentic and when
you're not and you know I don't think I
couldn't I don't know I just couldn't do
that with song and dance anymore where
I'm not being honest about who I am and
the things that are support